yeah video game high school doesn't want
to go problem to have because it means
that you know people are interested in
the content so I due to less propulsion
my crimes Bank of a facebook fan page
and twitter followers but we worked
really really hard on the product so
so for me I feel it YouTube in some
senses alerts IMDb where you email them
something and you get back like this
this blanket response have you ever had
one of your videos pool by youtube and
if so what's your relationship like with
them and what's the best way to contact
I had think my work with the other video
pool just happened out of nowhere their
channel was one word monetizing before
it just not I can't monetize but at
VidCon which is like the best place ever
for content creators I actually met a
attorney oh you took a talk until just
that you know if your video has been
taken down or unjust later and youtube
doesn't respond or give you a reason his
job is just what I help me to fight that
bad
yeah literally
I have I did a parody of a
and the saga
average homeboy this white rapper he
apparently took offense something
I had another videos back and that point
had two videos flag you lost your own
channels I lost my whole channel
hi
and
pulled by Warner Brothers
I wrote them back this is a charity
wait two weeks after two weeks the dis
one lakh up
unless they wanted they do at that point
when I say de Paradis they came back and
did something to me the corn help
because
I haven't had any people but my friend
had one for no reason and could not get
an answer back as to why and then that
means he lost his ad revenue as well and
he's been fighting it so what he ended
up doing is restarting another channel
because he could not get a response I
don't know that there were humans on the
other side of those emails so that was
just really frustrated because he didn't
even know why there was a reason
just one day his videos were gone I mean
how scary is that that there's this
entity that sort of that you're making
money from and you can sort of have it
old lose that and you have control how
scary is that sort of water or didn't do
to get around it's pretty terrifying but
we are in the film industry so that is
kind of our day to day job no matter
what you're doing what they're actually
making movies or television or you know
the fact that garmin can get fired off a
community maybe it can happen any time
it i guess it's the life we chose so
it's terrifying but i guess you just
wait till it happens hope that it
doesn't and when it does survive make do
somehow
all right let's continue to get you guys
in here any questions that haven't
surfaced yet we want to continue to be
but no we're coming down to like our
last a lot of swing here so we'll make
sure that you guys have some questions
that are lingering we haven't touched on
something Brian will give it to you
initially of how much of planning your
content here towards the genres
after amusement
side by being sir you really trying here
to purchase content
yeah i just wanted to go for things that
i know and i think that's more organic
ethic audience we will see through if
you're like others you know if you don't
know what serve the world ain't trying
to create for that world you're not
necessarily going to give the beans from
that world so i think it is important to
be great which you know and that's what
I've been with some of my questions
because i feel like i can speak to that
i can endlessly create content but if
you want to produce other content that
you feel you know other people if you
know a nerd or a sci-fi king who knows
that world and what I'm saying out
giving my deputies of you put it on my
channel I think that's the way that a
lot of users and networks are going
right now so I think it all depends but
if you if you're just trying to make
money and it might not necessarily be
the same would try doing my own video
player but i think that YouTube right
now is just killing the game because you
have a subscription base if you have
people constantly just come back and you
to do is very supportive about spreading
the word about our content once you do
become a partner they they really try to
be accommodating of it and help you out
the best way they can so
yeah I'm pretty glad to YouTube right
now are you also talked about
I'd like to be on hulu YouTube's pretty
good i was on myspace but myspace is
dead I Funny or Die but the audience
this isn't there these are the other
websites and there's not really way to
garner real the community or families so
having a real fan base on YouTube is
great and touching back to one of the
other question questions I don't know
like if you're worrying about if your
channel is going to go away or something
I think that's why people have their
website so they can take that fan base
and gear them towards other things like
the fan pages and stuff like that so
there's ways to keep your audience even
if you lose the YouTube channel um just
just answered that question which I've
already forgot what was it again I had a
good answer though no in terms of
staying on YouTube of the platform yeah
you do I mean you could go to other
networks I I try to start it off youtube
and I've gone on other different things
and even hulu I were going to show it's
on hulu and I got picked up by HT met
but the difference is is that um it's
kind of like going to a park that's
empty setting up a stage putting on the
show and biting all your friends to go
or going to the state fair and setting
up a stage and start doing your show
like YouTube is the state fair that's
where everyone already is so there's no
point in going through all the extra
work of going to someplace by yourself
just you can have your own player
because you like it to be a certain
dimension when there's no one's going to
hear you screaming into the void um
that's not a really bleep but my point
is is YouTube is great it's a great
network everybody who's on YouTube is
very supportive even to each other with
the other videos and YouTube itself is
you know even though they can be
terrifying at times I'm very supportive
and that's just where the audience is
and then to answer your question about
what works I I think you need to do what
you know but you also need to know your
demographic and what audience is online
a lot um if you're if you're going to be
making a web series about people who
hiked the Himalayas they're not on
line they were hiking the Himalayas so
you definitely want to try to find a
demographic of people that you know will
be spending a lot of time online whether
it's office workers or people who play
World of Warcraft or whatever that is
like that just a smart place to go to
start
no I loved for you guys to touch on that
moment where you know you're sort of
doing YouTube in these videos out of the
passion of it and then all of a sudden
you know something changed you know I
know it you know I guess let the money's
coming in a little bit and you're just
like you know what let me take this a
little bit soon let me push this further
key can you talk about but just butt
kick can you just going to touch on the
moment no yeah i think work that's been
more recently whereas before I wouldn't
really care about like if I put content
out there and it's just like whatever I
don't care about these people and one
more people to watch then I felt more
pressure I feel more pressure now about
what I put out because there aren't
eyeballs watching so that really sucks
and then I feel more responsibility and
I hate that but I have to remember like
okay this is like why I started in the
first place is because I wanted to
create content create my own content
oh no where he started my wife I told
her I would give this six months because
she wanted to know that like there would
be an end if this wasn't working and so
I said just give me six months and and
I'll know pretty soon whether or not
like it's getting any sort of traction
that this is working l and luckily like
a month after we started PBS got in
touch with us and we didn't sign that
contract for over twenty six months
later but I got that was really lucky
that that happened and well we haven't
monetized yet there have been little
small wins along the way that have said
okay we're moving in the right direction
and even though we have a long way ahead
of us it feels like we've gotten farther
in the past year of doing these web
videos on YouTube than we had
individually in the prior like 10 years
of making content and not looking I just
made videos that I thought were funny
and luckily other people thought they
were funny but now the algorithm for
Google for YouTube has changed and
there's likes problems with subscriber
mont modules and stuff so much my views
have gone down greatly so now I'm at a
point like I got this good sign to his
network and my views are so low and I
gotta figure out a way to get hit so now
I'm like I have to do some crap that I
don't want to do but at the same because
no it's like a job now you choose more
like a job when there's money involved
some
um so the five past few years of all my
involvement in YouTube I've always just
kept one foot out I actually pay my
bills doing stunts morphin voiceover so
it's a completely different world time
is when for fun I created a show about
something I love which was the gate
therapy and then it got hot and then now
we have money to actually make it and
there's a there's worth giving salaries
and we're getting paid for rewrites and
all this other stuff through the Stanley
channel so that was probably the moment
where I was like oh I love this but for
me that was my creative release you know
it wasn't something that I took very
seriously I just knew that I knew that
it was the future but I wasn't I knew I
wasn't ready for it and I just knew that
this was where the money was and I
didn't know where the money was here yet
but then once that show got licensed I
was like oh ok let's go I'm ready so
that was probably the moment when I got
that email that said stanley and geek
therapy in the subject line i have it
st. you know and steven heat oh he
touched upon the perception you know i
mean you know we've had people say this
is Los Angeles a lot of a lot of people
in the professional filmmaking world you
know how have we all have our own
perceptions about people that are doing
internet content that are putting stuff
up on the web I'm looking down on it can
you talk about your own life as time is
going on now maybe how the perception
has been going to change or has it got
to change the terms of how people will
get what you're doing
before it was hard because I did go to
Stanford a lot of my friends are doctors
lawyers you know doing important things
and after graduation at the Christmas
party be like Oh see your stomach in
youtube videos effort to make youtube
videos so now i do feel like because
there is more of an audience tonight
because i didn't want to be an artist
and a filmmaker and because you know
people are acknowledging what i do
instead of respecting what i do that
that helps at these parties so that's
what's change yeah actually because I've
made a feature a couple years ago or few
years ago and you know that's always a
hassle and a hustle and a pain in the
ass but when Steve and I started doing
this I had a lot of filmmaker friends
who are like oh wow you're like a 15
year old blogger now that's what you're
doing it like and I was like you know
you but um you know like just like
there's even one guy in particular I
remember he was like oh you're losing
like your indie cred like your ad you're
all this other stuff but you're being
kind of a clown online whatever and I
was like dude what breed people knew me
with that like reputation who cares but
subsequently like that guy that to come
back to us like has such a print by so
I'm like how to do what we're doing and
he tweets about it's like oh like where
his man crushes and although my hey
that's dope but like stop so yeah I mean
it's it's the whole thing for us is like
yeah we do we do like this this thing
with this show me and Steve but like
it's part of like the very beginning I
not i mean like planning other stuff you
know it's just just yeah
start I guess I just want to say they're
just for a moment so you know that he
has a beautiful film mr. sad man that
we've seen and then it's video so talk
can you talk a little bit more about to
the inner turmoil you know that this bed
taking that leap you know it's like I'm
really gonna do this and just give us
more on that Patrick and you got any
tissues yeah yeah so like I've only
known Steve for about a couple years met
at a film festival in 2010 and you know
like we both um as filmmakers we're kind
of like at a point where we're like oh
how do we make something work to get
like an interest in in new media an
audience building you like just hustling
online and finally we figure out a way
to work together and do something like
this but um it was a question sir
because you yourself are one of these
skeptical filmmakers that didn't want to
do this and now you are so can you go
back to those days when you were just
like man should I really be doing this I
mean like I I was never really like to
skeptical about this stuff like when
steve says that he you know they did
filmmakers who were like I'm better than
YouTube like I never thought I was
better than I just never thought about
it you know and it just kind of hit one
day and for me like you know like I was
always interested in what musicians were
doing because it always like one step
out of the game and it was like oh
they'll that whole idea like you do
something consistently consistently
consistently and as a filmmaker that's
really hard to do you like how do you
turn out something on a weekly basis so
you lose relevance you don't lose
relevance and so the like you know we
put it on something once a week and it
works for us and so like that has
actually helped us because you make a
feature film disappear for like eight
years here director for 17 days you know
and you know it's just like more people
to see our videos that I've seen our
work come by every single film you've
made
separately no
anyone want to jump in John can you know
as we headed to the final segment here
you know you know we're talking about
monetizing YouTube and creating these
videos can we also touch on some of the
opportunities and you guys have talked
about you know PBS opening up you know
he said can you talk about maybe some of
the opportunity that you didn't see
coming you know as you started the post
content just Kia just some the
opportunities that come your way just
being approached by different brands
being approached by enough around
William so I listened to it and move on
high school that was really really cool
kick-started was the biggest surprise
because I'm very prideful in terms of
asking people for money to to do stuff
so even when we were gonna do our
Kickstarter campaign people have been
contacting me asking if they could
donate money but I'm really feel
comfortable just taking money like that
and so that platform you were only
initially gonna ask for like five
thousand dollars because honestly our
show is predominantly black and we were
like it was Duncan running yes oh
that that really surprised as we made
our goal thirty thousand dollars and
people gape above and beyond and raised
over 56,000 continued episode so that
was a huge deal for me and I was like
wow people really want to see this
content and they're really um they're
really willing to support it so I would
have never imagined that
in the film and television world I the
name dropping them all night so I
apologize but like Jerry Zucker and
Stanley Mark Hamill like incredible
people that I idolized i'm sending on
panels with now because of YouTube the
other thing is is that it's also i'm
working on this feature film that I
think we're shooting at the end of the
year actually two feature films both of
what you're using the internet one is
using it in terms of gaining their
audience now so that when we start to do
the for walling at the end um so through
videos and through forums and stuff
they're canyon or in their internet or
their audience now for for later
basically trying to base it off the
paranormal activity um model which just
did really well obviously and then the
other one is is a dabbling with a live
streaming actually which is a little bit
off the youtube topic but um i think the
coolest thing that I didn't expect um
both the people i mean you get the
trolls of course they're just they're
they're going to be there and with their
comments of like take off your shirt but
but then what you also get are the
people who are so supportive and so
loving and are constantly telling you
that they love your work and even better
giving you ideas they just give them
away and there's so much better than a
lot of the things that you thought of
yourself um and so that's been an
incredible resource just today somebody
tweeted at me something and I was like
I'm doing it thanks we're gonna do I'm
gonna take that um so that's it that to
me more than the money the chance to be
able to express myself and to know that
I have people out there who feel the
same way I found my people I think
that's the best gift
I got my brother at jimmy kimmel down
pretty cool this working with other
talented people James in linking
lifelong friends that are also youtubers
an intense as they really cool i love
his brother Albert love love your
brother right so when we were at VidCon
we got to talk to the double rainbow guy
also jimmy kimmel alum and we asked him
what's your advice to baby youtubers
meeting people that are new green and
industry I'm curious as to what he said
yeah crying time just imagine I would
say that my advice is I never come back
to me I'd make short videos of it I see
I'm short of in short videos honestly
and I see a lot of people who are
premiering videos and primary chose for
the first time and it's like 12 minutes
and I'm like who do you think you wanna
that I'm going to sit up here and watch
sure 12-minute video and I don't know
you I think it's really really helpful
to have like um less than four minute
video so that's my only advice now I'm
yeah I'm just say like do your homework
and just just start making things get
started on it you know like do your
homework meaning like yeah don't make a
15-minute video just
no it works and diesel that you like I
posted my first video in 2006 but i
never posted content regularly on
youtube and there's a lot that i didn't
really understand and YouTube put
together this YouTube creator playbook
that goes into a lot of ideas on like
how to be successful on YouTube from you
know getting title like threading the
right subject headline and you know
putting the right tags and researching
my tags to put on your videos and you
know annotations so you can you know
link to other videos you've made or back
to your channel and just a lot of
there's a lot to YouTube to learn them
are we did a video a couple weeks ago
with wongfuproductions which is these
these filmmakers and they have like 1.2
million subscribers on YouTube and
because an interview and they a couple
days after we posted it they retweeted
are to be to the video and that's like
oh cool like we started getting you know
like all these people subscribing and
people watching it and it became our
most viewed video and later look I
looked at the analytics on YouTube for
where this traffic was coming from but I
thought it was probably Twitter but it
wasn't it was actually they had liked
the video on YouTube and so because they
liked it like their 1.2 million
subscribers saw that they liked it and
so we put a hub nail that have a picture
of them and then something clicked on it
you know I never would have known like
the power of a like from the channel
that has a million subscribers before
but so there's a lot to learn about how
YouTube works I get on a regular
schedule collaborate find when you like
you think other people like and make
bunch of crap um yeah basically what
they said just do it just don't get
stuck in your head don't be worried
about is it good enough you'll learn as
you go and then find people to use as
role models um you can find a video on
how to run a camera you can find a video
on how to lie to seeing you couldn't
find a video on how to edit it you can
find the video to do anything that you
need so let go to their channel their
their film school right that's basically
no it's not don't go to their channel
but finds another channel that's why
don't um just do it cuz you
learn as you go and then as you start
doing it and start putting yourself out
there you'll meet other people who'll
say by the way do that hey be it by the
way do that um but don't get stuck in
your head and then never make it because
then that'll just be the saddest option
but being revered for the trolls that's
what I would say don't read the comments
all right I think that does it thank you
all very much thank you